hallo mein name ist luca meine lieben
freunde ich darf ich heute am dienstag
endlich mal wieder begrüßen zu einer
neuen episode tik tok tuesday und ich
würde sagen wir verdienen gar nicht
lange zeit und startet mit dem ersten
tik tok wo drei jungs mit schnee
basketball spielen
[Musik]
von ahlmann der tanz um die ecke kommt
und sagt da könnten steine drin was rein
sicher weg
was machst du hier sieht einfach aus wie
montana black und zwei jahren
[Musik]
sie ist einfach kurze alarmanlage
geworden
na
gut und mir auch gut
dass ich noch viel komischer finde ich
gut und gut
aber dann müsste genauso an der stelle
liebe grüße an sandra haas trinkt deine
mission er wann hast du zuletzt
habe man hin und
du
lukas so verspricht man ja nicht so was
mache ich auch nicht seid ihr des
wahnsinns
lukas an der stelle auch noch mal ganz
liebe grüße an sandra
geht's los und alles aber die road wenn
dich unsympathisch
anstatt sich irgendwie über lust machen
oder keine ahnung in welche vorwurf zu
machen sei zu fragen warum ich brauche
und nicht irgendwie
frage ich mich wirklich wie es sein kann
dass wir mit solchen menschen unseren
planeten teilen
warum rauchst du ewig ich komme aus
frankfurt brauchen alle
einfach eins zu eins die lager nach
gemacht wenn sie nahe sieht
[Musik]
keine ahnung was das jetzt eure sprache
war
ich bin einfach mittlerweile zuvor nicht
zu erschrecken
[Musik]
dings
kann man praktikum machen
23 uhr und 5 uhr aber weil wir wollen ja
nicht unsere zahlen haben mich
einfach noch viel mehr wie ihr da noch
so viel stehen haben könnt wenn die ba
angeblich seit sechs stunden geschlossen
hat
[Musik]
wie schreibt mir gesoffen
wofür
brauchst du salz und pfefferstreuer die
so groß sind
groß reicht so ein kleines ding ich will
hier keinen stabhochsprung machen beim
essen makkaroni mit
schicken
ich bin noch fit eindeutig zweites gold
[Applaus]
an der stelle ganz liebe grüße an meine
mutter leute ich habe diese erdbeben
und mit dem springen zusammen
mir fällt einfach jetzt als auf dass er
1 1 aus sind wie ali von goodgame
mein beileid an dass sie die serie doch
nicht geguckt haben
ich habe hier gab mein schnitzel
eingelegt
und jetzt kommen diese flecken also
ich will dir wirklich nicht in dein
leben reden
macht wie du meinst aber es gibt so was
das heißt teller
ganz neu
das war einfach eins zu eins ich damals
in der schule wenn ich meine
hausaufgaben vorstellen sollte
ich bin so froh nicht mehr in der schule
zu sein
dass normaler montag wenn man erst
beiden stunden mathe hat
keynote butter
[Musik]
das war natürlich eins ich glaube
sprachen lernen er hat gerade gesagt
keiner würde mich denken aber ich hatte
sein vater letzten acht
was hat sein vater letzen acht
gegessen
womit der spieler fast good game
türkische version
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wm-titel
er ist nichts machen das ist jetzt halt
einfach keine fledermaus männer
sondern
ich sollte echt ein kanal löschen
also ja dass sie da vom stuhl fällt und
dass das witzig ist schön und gut aber
was war das für eine teufels lache
hallo
führen sie englisch
stabil ich bekomme bitte einmal einen
doppelpack menü eine stuntshow
ich verstehe gar nichts mehr oben
[Musik]
zu schauen habe ich angst bekommen ich
bin geimpft
meinung dass
meine cousinen ist mein hund ist sogar
ich mag das nicht ich kann mich impfen
ich kann dich ich habe gar nicht gemerkt
dass ich hier mit zwei gabeln gerade
esse sie waren zusammen
läuft
naja dann ist das also das
wahrscheinlich aus
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sorry browser dein hund sieht halt auch
schon so aus als wird er ohne leckerli
gar nichts machen
der hätte eigentlich als katze geboren
werden müssen sind hier luna ich habe
dir doch gesagt du darfst du in mein
zimmer
immer wieder
bevor hier wieder youtuber ankommen und
sagen hör oder wir den tieren schaden
zugefügt das war ein stofftier
und den alltag schon einmal traurig wie
das
war eins zu eins meine englischlehrerin
damals
if you stayed
lovely greetings an der stelle wird das
heute ich will das eigentlich auch
beenden meine lieben freunde wenn euch
hier heute am dienstag endlich mal
wieder eine neue episode tik tok tuesday
gefallen lassen einen daumen hoch unter
dem video hier da abonniert main kanal
und tickt auf die glocke wenn ich eine
benachrichtigung bekommen wollt sobald
ich ein neues video hochladen morgen um
18 uhr geht es weiter mit minecraft mit
luca und hier
könnt ihr mich abonnieren oder halten
euch ein anderes video anschauen
ich kann euch eigentlich beides nicht so
richtig empfehlen aber
macht es einfach